le président du service départemental
d'incendié et de secours de la baie de
la martinique et belfort birota bonjour
bonjour monsieur viol ton bonjour les
auditeurs de martine première bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sapeurs
pompiers la contestation qui se poursuit
avec les hommes du feu ils exigent une
rencontre avec le président du conseil
exécutif alfred marie jeanne
on s'en rapproche même forme hirota je
ne peux pas vous répondre tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que à mon avis
toute grève vise à l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des agents et
légitime et l'employeur doit dans la
mesure de ses possibilités financières
mais pas aux attentes de revendications
du personnel de la mesure où ceux-ci
ces derniers ne sortant pas tu ne
sortent pas du 4-2 lors de leurs
compétences à des oeillets vite et
éviter la collision
aujourd'hui tout le tous les protocoles
d'accord signés ont été satisfaits à
plus de 75 broussan le dernier protocole
d'accord celui du 16 avril 2019 a déjà
reçu certaines réponses positives
ouais je rappelle qu'une revendication
isat de l'époque où le diable était
petit garçon belfort birota or les
hommes du feu continue à dire je n'étais
là même exercer leur métier d'être payé
en temps et en heure une omission
problèmes qui me concerne aujourd'hui la
grève comme vous dites dû à un retard de
versement du salaire a aussi trouvé une
issue favorable puisque suite à une
réunion que j'ai eue avec l intéressé
lui avec les syndicats
aucune formation du seul la salle était
pleine nous avons acté de commun accord
certain nombre de décisions
les jeux j'ai pour mon que monsieur
engagé avait assez des agios je me suis
engagé à donner des compensations
financières
si le salaire n'est pas versé le 6
j'ai dû même accepté de donner à pour
ceux qui en feront la demande qui en
feraient la demande
un mode essence en boue sable tout cela
pour essayer de le rendre plus comment
dire
certaines années sociale les conditions
qui ne dépendent pas du tout c'est bon
c'est la liberté du travail
entre-temps la crise en public à payer à
procéder au paiement des salaires
le moment je suis où je vous parle je
crois que tous les salaires sont partis
en direction des bahamas
toujours est-il monsieur monsieur le
temps que j'ai la conviction d'avoir
fait correctement mon travail de
certains agents veulent continuer à
faire la grève
prenons compris text mes propos qu'il
juge diffamatoires à celui qui avait
allumé le feu mais certaines
déclarations quand même on faisait
souffler sur des braises là avec
personnel y ferait plus que leur boulot
je travaille jeunes souffrent tout le
monde sait connaît cette situation aura
et a pas cependant ce que tout le monde
voulait qu sapeurs pompiers
professionnels qui font de la formation
il ya tout le monde le sait des
sapeurs-pompiers qui exercent une
activité à l'extérieur sous leur réveil
j'ai un jour de travail je n'ai pas dit
ça je ne sais pas ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que j'ai en main au moment où
je vous parle suffisamment de couillet
émanant d'organismes officiels notamment
du directeur de la mer notamment de
société privée de gardiennage qui me
disent que mes agents est trouble
perturbant quelque sorte le bon
fonctionnement d'un service parce qu'il
faut ils viennent travailler chez bon
jeu non je me refuse de suivre ses
agents la leçon combien son combi
représenterait quels jeunes ce qu'est
prête je ne sais pas cela me semblait
pas dessus oui une autre foire ça c'est
fait en fait seul comment faire de
remédier comment faire pour y remédier
eh bien j'ai gens refusent dessus ces
personnes dans cette impasse la fois
qu'on a dit ça c'est pourquoi je n'ai
pas répondu à cette injonction qui m'a
été faite par un syndicaliste de me
présenter à la barre du tribunal de nous
mêmes
devant le disque et lundi derniers je
n'ai pas répondu je ne répondrai pas je
préfère analyser avec comment dire
beaucoup d'intérêt les propos de notre
délégation du cannet stream qui
s'appelle i la patrie syndicat ssp
pattes qui a touché du doigt le cas du
problème quel est ce problème lui il
parle de mauvaise gestion du sdiss
pourrait gestion financière il parle
également du financement de 10 c'est
vrai que lorsque je suis arrivé j'ai
constaté une mauvaise gestion des stocks
j'ai constaté une mauvaise gestion de la
hausse des ressources humaines
oui j'ai constaté une mauvaise gestion
du parc automobile
j'ai constaté également de mauvaise
gestion de l'atelier et c'est pouvoir
une fois que j'ai fort directeur de sa
dalle et à l'optimisation de la
ressource en personne
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît on sent
bien que vous vouliez protée du doigt
certains dysfonctionnements mais par
exemple syndicats à venir secours
estiment que fait un amalgame dangereux
entre la majorité des sapeurs pompiers
qui exercent leur messie leur métier en
âme et conscience
et puis peut-être une minorité qui
qui n'a pas toujours le comportement
approprié lorsqu'on signe un contrat
lorsque pour signer une fiche de poste
qui fait pas le boulot que vous les
remettre au travail
il n'ya pas une autre façon de faire
pour s'amuser se reconnaîtra et jeu
c'est facile de dire ça je l'attendais
président du stif jeu match est née de
ce que j'ai dit je maintiens ce que j'ai
dit si cette minorité estime que qu'elle
a été diffamé
il y a les tribunes qu'on me poursuive
au tribunal c'est aussi cela par contre
moi je préfère m'arrêter à des propos
plus réfléchie et plus constructif sur
les propos de monsieur de mentionner ce
torride et vous semblez d'assister
belfort birota je voulais tellement
détestés belfort birota si dense dans ce
corps de métiers représentés sapeurs
pompiers il ya une petite minorité de
personnes qui vaquent à leurs
occupations personnelles sur leur temps
de travail je les avais vus sur le temps
de travail ne me fait pas désorganisées
quand vous dites que des gens un fonds
exercent d'autres nouvelles activités et
vous voulez un exemple lorsque le
directeur de la mer mme écrit pour me
dire que jeune j'ai un agent sapeurs
pompiers professionnels qui est à oleko
marais deschamps je fais quoi moi je
rêve je ferme la bouche
je n'ai pas le droit d'attirer
l'attention des services là dessus on
peut être entrepreneur est ce que le
statut de fonctionnaire permet d'être
toujours preneur trompé abbiati fij mais
devra se séparer les voit bien toute
activité a goûté aux minimes
ouais et est-ce que vous avez les moyens
aujourd'hui belfort birota de nettoyer
cela monsieur c'est pas mon souci sein
du clan ben je sais j'ai dû céder qui
donnerait de 2,2 ce qui m'intéresse ce
qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est comment sortir 9 10
de cette situation financière
catastrophe les mots les communes qui ne
paie pas en temps et en heure est ce que
il pourrait avoir quelque chose
d'efficace de concret pour que je ne
peux pas tout ce qui était humainement
possible
nous avons signé avec les communes de
combat des conventions d'un mythe de
mensualisation certaines communes paige
rappelle par moments je vous parle nous
sommes là au début mais nous avons
encaissé seulement 19 % des 10 millions
7 que les communes doivent alors que le
p r départemental et avertit la préfète
averti et bien à est de faire aussi le
boulot c'est pas moi qui aie contre 2
les maires de verser l'argent qui ne
veulent pas laisser et tout le monde
c'est parce que là nous avons l'art dans
ce pays de passer à côté des vrais pour
5 secondes
le vrai problème c'est le financement de
l'isis versoo la monnaie connaissent
disent les 19 ans sont en difficulté
tout le monde sait ça alors je suis prêt
aujourd'hui si on m'a offert à damon de
venez discuter du fidesz mois du 10 avec
mes recyclage
merci belfort birota président du ciss
martinique merci d'avoir tu ce soit dans
son rôle ce matin